What we need to speak about
is how to ensure the place and role Europe deserves
in the construction of this new world.
This Europe will be more confident
and more attentive to other populations.
Since the origins of the European Community,
I - like many of you - have defended the idea
of building a social Europe.
Today, we have traced the outlines of a social Europe
but there is no content.
Wouldn't it be an exhilarating,
fascinating task to create this content?
A Europe of cultures, ladies and gentlemen,
is a Europe of nations against nationalism.
As chance would have it,
I was born during the First World War
and fought in the second.
I lived my childhood against a backdrop of broken families,
mourning their dead and harbouring bitterness,
sometimes hatred, towards their recent enemies.
We need to pass on, not this hatred,
but on the contrary the chance of a reconciliation
that we owe to those of 1944 – 1945
who had the audacity to envisage a brighter future,
based on reconciliation and peace.
That's what we've done.
Nationalism is war!
War is not just in the past, it could also be in our future.
It's us, you, ladies and gentlemen members of Parliament,
who are the guardians of peace.